so a key-value store is in essence a
distributed hash table it is a way for
you to store very simple objects blobs
or whatever it cross a cluster of
machines and what the cluster does is it
provides all the maintenance and
failover for you so that you can really
store an enormous number of Records with
extremely low latencies keep key value
stores actually the simplest thing to
describe if you have a piece of data you
give it a name and you say store it it's
actually not that different from how you
would store files on a file system the
advantage of a key value store is it
does this in a massively distributed way
where the nodes themselves can handle
failures and the data is replicated now
what's interesting about key value
stores is that these are systems that
are designed to have to handle truly
massive amounts of traffic
so in our test with the major key value
store vendors like Couchbase and
aerospike these vendors are both able to
handle transaction volumes into the
millions of Records per second
millions of operations per second that's
something they were able to do without
too much trouble now where these
databases tend to blur a bit is both
aerospike and Couchbase the two biggest
key value vendors that we encounter they
have both added document functionality
in recent releases within the past seven
or eight months so the line between
document databases and key value stores
is a bit blurred similarly even though
the secondary index support on these
column stores has also blurred the lines
a bit between document databases and
column families stores making the
distinction between them a little bit
harder to gauge it's more of one of
nuance than have completely different
types and I should say last of all that
document databases and column family
databases do store their data by keys
they are also key
stores and can function perfectly
adequately as a key value store
themselves so the real distinction is
are you more interested in raw scale and
raw power are you more interested in
functionality on the edge cases around
document indexing and so forth or or one
of the use cases alike time series data
that column families have been really
effective at